Варшава, кінець липня. Опозиція закликає до простестів.
На вулицях – стотисячний натовп.
Люди незгодні з держаними перетвореннями
ініційованими націонал-консервативним урядом Польщі.
"Рубікон перейдено.
Вони відкрито розтоптали Конституцію.
Ми повертаємося у 1989-й"
Що за Рубікон має на увазі цей чоловік?
Хто стоїть з одного, а хто – з іншого боку?
Тріумф націонал-консерваторів розпочався 2015 року в парламенті
Партія "Право і справедливість" здобула абсолютну більшість на виборах.
Тепер вона радикально перелицьовує державу.
За такий курс відповідає вона
прем'єр-міністерка Беата Шидло
"Опозиція роздмухує екстремальні пристрасті
але політичні пристрасті не мають нічого спільного
із актуальною ситуацією в країні "
Утім, Шидло - лише виконавиця.
За її політикою стоїть він – реальний політичний лідер Польщі
голова партії "Право і справедливість" Ярослав Качинський
Система, яку ми наразі змінюємо, була вкрай корумпованою.
Приміром, мас-медіа, четверта гілка влади.
Уряд зміцнив свої повноваження
щодо контролю над державним телерадіомовленням
Неугодних редакторів звільнили й замінили лояльними до влади
Крім того, правляча партія обмежила
доступ преси до парламенту.
Опозиційні партії виступили проти цього.
На чолі протестів – Гжегож Схетина
голова "Громадянської платформи" – найбільшої опозиційної партії
А також:
Ришард Петру, лідер нової ліберальної партії "Новочесна"
Вони, щоправда, мало що можуть протиставити
абсолютній більшості "Права і справедливості"
Справжня опозиційна сила зростає тут – на вулицях
В інтернеті формуються численні громадянські рухи.
Ще один аспект – правосуддя.
Уряд намагається реорганізувати суди
критично налаштованих суддів відправити на пенсію
а на їхні місця призначити нових, близьких до влади
Експерти застерігають
це стане кінцем правової держави
Протест – у розпалі.
По всій Польщі люди виходять на вулиці
Осторонь не залишаються й "ікони" польського визвольного руху
"Моє покоління перемогло у дуже складній ситуації.
Польща стала вільною країною, із відокремленими гілками влади.
Це було нашим найважливішим досягненням.
Тож ви, й передусім молодь
нікому не можете дозволити забрати це"
Протести зростають не лише у Варшаві
а й у регіонах, де "Право і справедливість" має найбільше прибічників
Дедалі більше громадян обурені тим
що реформи польських консерваторів можуть поставити хрест на польській демократії.